We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
an interesting question about Trump and his
helicopter.
Take a listen to this.
Hello.
I was just wondering, can you figure out why
does Trump stand outside with a helicopter
running all the time?
[inaudible] talking to the press, you know,
I mean, I, I don't get it.
Is he trying to look like I'm flying all around?
I'm sure important.
There's always a helicopter waiting for me.
Why does he do that?
Stand out there and yell war Katy.
Go out there when the helicopters not chopping
around and the wind isn't blowing.
Yeah.
So listen, th this is partially a power move.
I Trump, Trump likes it.
The I, I'll, I'll throw you a bone by being
willing to talk to you while my helicopter
waits with the rotor spinning in the background.
Part of it is that reporters wait to try to
get Trump to answer their questions on the
walk from, you know, the white house or wherever
over to the helicopter.
So I think it's a combination of things and
I understand that when it's so hard to actually
get Donald Trump to answer questions, you'll
take any opportunity as a reporter, even with
a hat, with a helicopter blades worrying in
the background.
But you can tell Trump just absolutely loves
it and does see it as a, as a sort of power
move.
We'll talk on the bonus show today about Donald
Trump, a mocking a teen climate activists,
Gretta tune Berg Thornburg.
I'm not exactly sure how to pronounce her
name.
Uh, we will talk about Trump mocking her.
We will talk about Indonesia raising the minimum
age for brides in an attempt to maybe end
child marriage and much, much more.
Become a member and get instant access for
the bonus show by signing up@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.